welcome to another famous friday where
we look at how you can learn
from successful entrepreneurs and apply
what made them successful
to your business today's lesson is
care okay this might be a novel concept
for a lot of businesses but
you have to actually care about the
people who work for you
about your customers about your
community if you care about them then
guess what
they're gonna care about you and they're
going to give you more business they're
going to give you more money they're
going to refer more customers to you
if you actually care about them this
isn't that hard a strategy
one of my favorite entrepreneurs is
milton hershey there's so many great
reasons to love milton hershey but the
story i want to share with you today is
about how he really
cared about his team and his community
in 1929 the great depression hit
and everybody was laying people off was
firing people right they're trying to
save money save on costs and that just
made everything worse because now more
people didn't have jobs
milton hershey who founded hershey
chocolate said you know what i want to
be the change i want to
i want to try to kick start something i
think this is a great opportunity to
care about our community
and he decided to hire people to start a
community
works project that had nothing to do
with chocolate he started
hiring people to build a school to build
a sports arena to build a rec center and
to build a hotel
like what does that have to do with
chocolate
nothing but he's contributing to his
community and that's going to help his
company grow
and there's one famous story where he
was building his hotel
and somebody comes to him and say hey
milton you know we can uh
we've discovered this new shovel and
it's called a steam shovel and it can do
the work of 40 men
you can build your hotel so much faster
and he told the guy
forget the shovel hire the 40 men
because that was the whole point of this
project was to create jobs
and create a sense of community again
and uplift people's spirits
and you may be thinking well that's a
stupid decision
he could have he could have saved money
on those 40 jobs and you're thinking
short term you're playing the small game
where milton hershey understood that he
had to play a bigger game and that's the
long game and you have to care
and caring will often mean that you know
what
it may not make the most sense in a
short-term decision
but you can bet that those 40 people
will be loyal to milton hershey
forever and you can bet that their
friends and their family will be loyal
to milton hershey
forever and buy his products and rave
about his company
and the community that he built all
those things for will love milton
hershey
forever and now 2014
almost a century later i'm making a
video about it and other people are
still talking about it and this legend
and this story of milton hershey
continues to perpetuate how much value
has that added
to the hershey company and their bottom
line
way more than the cost of those 40 jobs
their salaries so you have to care
tap into your heart think about the
people who work for you
think about the customers who buy from
you think about the community that
you're part of
and do something today to show that you
actually
care about them because if you care
about them
they'll care about you believe
for those you watching like the video
you can subscribe to the channel to see
more videos
just like this thank you so much i'll
see you soon